we are now going to talk about valence
electrons and non valence electrons
which are known as core electrons and so
one question that you might have been
asking yourself this whole time that
we've been looking at electron
configurations is what is the point and
the point of electron configurations is
is they can give us insight as to how a
given atom or how a given element is
likely to react with other atoms and so
just to make that point or make it a
little bit clearer let's look at the
electron configuration of an element
that will see a lot of in chemistry of
oxygen so oxygens electron configuration
is what pause this video and see if you
can work through that well in a neutral
oxygen atom you have eight protons and
eight electrons so first you were going
to fill the one shell then you are going
to start filling the second shell so
you're going to go to s 2 so I have 4
right now I have to have 4 more so then
you're going to have to P 4 and notice
if I add up all of the electrons here I
have exactly 8 electrons
now if I'm thinking about how my oxygen
react it's interesting to look at the
outer oxygen electrons the electrons
that are in the outermost shell so the
outermost shell is being described right
over here this second shell so how many
electrons are in the outermost shell you
have six electrons here so oxygen has
six valence valence electrons and how
many core electrons does it have and the
core electrons generally aren't reactive
or don't aren't involved as much in
reactions it has two core to core
electrons now why is six valence
electrons interesting
well atoms tend to be more stable when
they have a filled outer shell or in
most examples at least filled s and P
sub shells in their outer shell and so
in this situation you say okay oxygen
has six valence electrons and oftentimes
that's drawn with a Lewis structure and
it might look something like this where
oxygen has one two three four
five six valence electrons and you might
say hey it would be nice if oxygen
somehow were able to share or get ahold
of two more electrons because then that
outermost shell will have a full number
of eight electrons the 2s and the 2p
would be filled in we'd have two p6 and
so you say all right well maybe they can
grab those electrons from something else
and that's actually what oxygen does a
lot of it grabs electrons from other
things you could look at something like
calcium pause this video think about
what the electron configuration of
calcium is and then think about how
calcium is likely to react given that
atoms tend to be more stable when they
have a full outer shell where both their
s and P sub shells are completely filled
well calcium's electron configuration I
could do it in noble gas notation or
configuration it would have the electron
configuration of argon and one of the
reasons why the noble gases are so
stable is that they have a completely
full shell argon argon for example has a
completely full first shell second shell
and third shell and then to build
calcium will then have two electrons in
that fourth shell so it is argon and
then for s2 so how many valence
electrons does calcium have well you
could see it right over there it has two
valence valence electrons what about its
core electrons well a neutral calcium
atom would have twenty electrons because
it has 20 protons so it would have 18 18
core electrons electrons that are less
likely to react and so you could say
what's the easiest way for calcium to
get to a full outer shell well instead
of trying to gain six electrons it might
be a lot easier to just lose these two
electrons it is actually the case that
many times calcium will lose electrons
and become ionized will be caught will
get a positive charge so the big picture
here is one of the values of electron
configuration is to think about which of
your electrons are most likely to react
those are your valence electrons in most
case
your valence electrons are going to be
your outermost electrons they're going
to be the electrons in that outer most
shell generally speaking if you're
talking about elements that are in the s
block or the P block you can think about
with how many valence electrons they
have just based on what column they're
in this column right over here has one
valence electron this column over here
has two valence electrons
this column out here has three valence
electrons four valence electrons five
valence electrons six valence electrons
and seven valence electrons the noble
gas is here they are very unreactive so
one way to think about is they are very
very very stable they have filled their
outer shell